the one thing I've heard from people is
that you charge too little how do you
respond to that like if people say like
you charging ten bucks or twenty bucks a
month you know two hundred fifty dollars
a year to do all your e-commerce in a
dedicated site is absurd it's insane and
people would pay a lot more if you asked
your clients if this software didn't
exist how much would cost you it would
they would say five or ten thousand
dollars to hire somebody to set up a
competing service what do you answer to
that I usually just tell them be a
better at pricing and that's a that's
the truth of it it's maybe I regularly
talk with people who are converting from
like not just five thousand dollars
people are you often paying fifty
thousand dollars a month for their
systems that's a that's a fairly regular
price in our industry because you're
going from third parties we're building
the systems and they are hosting for you
and you being charged and all these kind
of things so converting to a patent on a
$170 plan and their service much better
prefer the nice thing about our
businesses we really want to just make
it a lot simpler for people to start
these kind of businesses because it's
hard you know like when we started there
was so much to learn there was you know
just how you're dealing with the
manufacturers supply chain how do you
get the word out there was a lot of
complexity around technology too like we
had to to get approved for credit card
gateway back then we had to post like
$10,000 down payment or bond with the
banks to do this kind of stuff we needed
to be you needed to engage for many many
thousands of dollars a year a company
doing PCI scanning for your site which
meant but the site had to be up but then
you couldn't get access to the to the
gateway credentials before you had the
test so it was a huge to connect program
doing development for us and it was just
hard so there's a lot of these kind of
problems we wanted to make go go away so
our business is focused on hey let's
let's make it so that everyone who has
products to sell like people with
interesting stuff but there's just
nothing in their way to get to get this
out and get them in the hands of people
that sort of up you care about and then
for us to as opportunities to monetize
of course we wanted to ask people to pay
money for this but there's also
opportunities for us to go for the
payment
shipping companies because economies of
scale matter in this business and you
can go to you know FedEx and say hey we
have sixty thousand people wanted
probably ship with you know that means
we can get better rates for everyone and
that means there's potentially some
opportunity for us to make money too